>>Presenter: Hello everyone and welcome to
yet another Google live installment of Authors
at Google in San Francisco. We've got today
a science writer, Marc Kaufman, speaking on
his book 'First Contact'. And although I can't
yet say we've definitively found life on other
planets, I think we've got a lot of great
updates from the science community as to how
far we've progressed and how close we're coming
to at least understanding what it means when
we say 'extraterrestrial life' and what we
could possibly learn from it. This is Marc's
first book. Although we're very excited to
showcase it, it will also be featured as part
of the National Book Festival in the National
Mall in DC. He's been interviewed on Fresh
Air on NPR and we are happy to welcome him
as part of the Authors at Google series. Thanks.
[applause]
>>Marc Kaufman: Thanks very much. Thank you
all very much. I am really delighted to be
here. I feel in a sense that we are kind of
kindred spirits in a sense that I was really
drawn into a subject that is extremely cutting
edge and that could not have existed 15 years
ago in terms of the kinds of information that's
really being generated now, just as you are.
We have knowledge and we have technology that
didn't exist before and we're now able to
find things that we couldn't before. So this
is a remarkable time particularly in this
world of, of life beyond earth. And just a
little bit about myself. I'm a reporter at
the Washington Post. I've been there for 10
years or so. I used to be at the Philadelphia
Inquirer. I've been a foreign correspondent
a lot and I'll get into it later. I kind of
came linked into being a science writer but
it is extraordinarily cool and I am very glad
I was able to do it. All right, so here we
go. This is, I put together some slides here
and we'll just kind of talk about them as
we go along. And feel free to ask questions
along the time, along the discussion.
As when you think about it, there has really
been since the beginning of humankind as far
as we know a desire, an instinct, to see life
or to feel that there is life in the skies.
You think about where's heaven? It's up in
the skies. Where's God? Up in the skies. Where,
where are angels? Or in more recent, more
secular days, E.T. and Star Wars and whatever
else. There's just kind of an innate desire
to, for that to be true. And that's, you kind
of wonder is that a, just a simple hope that
we're not alone in the world or in the universe
or is it something kind of instinctive, kind
of deep inside of us that we can't really
parse through. As, as this issue has been
dealt with over the years and it has been
very kind of vociferously argued going back
to the Greeks and Romans as to whether or
not there, there can be planets outside of
the Solar System and so on. And then life
outside it, it has all been on the basis of
belief because they didn't really have any
scientific knowledge to work with or they
would, there was a rational kind of aspect
to it where they would try to impute certain
knowledge but it really was ultimately based
on belief and in that sense, it ran into a
lot of obstacles.
This is a statue of Giordano Bruno who is
kind of the patron saint of astrobiology which
is the science that we're going to be talking
about today. He was a Dominican monk who later
became a free thinker of sorts and was a believer
in what was called the multiplicity of worlds
which meant he thought that there were a lot
of different planets out there and that there
were different people who lived on them or
different beings. And he was burned at the
stake. That was, he also had, had been involved
in what was considered a number of other heresies
but that was, I think, number two or three.
So it was , this is a subject that, that brings
up surprisingly strong emotions as again we
will get into in the future, as we go further.
But this is, as I saying before, kind of new
to human kind that there is, there really
is a science to ET life. It is called 'astrobiology'.
And it is a remarkable kind of umbrella discipline
in the sense that it includes everything from
microbiology, geo-microbiology, chemistry,
planetary science, geology, all the way to
cosmology. And it, none of those are themselves
necessarily astrobiology. But there has been
a real instinct in, in and an organized effort
in the last 10 years, or 15 years or so to
bring it together into a particular overriding
discipline. Every two years they have a, a
conference. There was one in Santa Clara two
years ago, one in Texas this year. About 10,000
people show up, some of the best and brightest
scientists on earth. And they, they talk about
astrobiology from the perspective of their
own fields for the most part. But it's all
with that, that movement forward toward, 'Hey,
we think that there's life out there and we're
gonna try to one, understand what that life
might be; two, how we might identify it; three,
how we could maybe figure out that it was
there once before and isn't there anymore'
and so on.
So there I've kind of taken to, to likening
it to a stealth Apollo program. It is a massive
effort. It's going on around the world. There
are tens, hundreds of thousands of scientists
involved in one way or another in, in the
pursuit but until recently very few people
have really known about it. And I think even
now, you know about specific bits of news
that come up but you don't necessarily, there
isn't a general understanding that this has
been hardwired into a NASA and the European
Space Administration and to the whole effort
of dealing with life beyond, with space issues
generally. Astrobiology is right at the center
of it.
As I was saying, I was a foreign correspondent,
a lot of other things until I became a science
writer five, six years ago. My editor said,
'You know, you should really learn a little
bit more about this.' So I went up to a journalism
boot camp at MIT and the subject was the universe.
We were supposed to learn about all, everything
in the universe in four days. I'm not sure
we succeeded but we did learn a lot about
super massive black holes, the Big Bang and
how galaxies are formed. And all of it was
deeply fascinating. But it wasn't until this
woman arrived that, that things really gelled
for me. She is, her name is Sara Seager. She
is a, she has a named chair at MIT and tenure
which she got at age 34. So you can imagine
that she is like a total whiz. And she got
up there and she said, 'In my lifetime, I
am almost virtually sure that we will find
life beyond Earth.' And there I was, at MIT,
and this was someone who obviously knew a
great deal about this and was speaking with
a lot of authority. So I said to myself, not
so much as a science, as a science, from the
perspective of science, since my perspective
in science then was somewhat limited. But
as a journalist, which I had been for a long
time, I said, 'What a story.' You know, no
one is really looking at this in the sense
of telling the, the public as it were that,
that is what the best and the brightest are
beginning to or have concluded, that we're
on that kind of trajectory and it's just a
question of time. Just want to start a little
bit in terms of stepping back. A lot of astrobiology
now involves the search for and the understanding
of microbial life and there's an instinct,
perhaps not here but in some places to say,
'Well they're just little microbes. You can't
see them. What's the big deal?' But as you
can see, for three billion of the 3.8 billion
years that there have been, that there has
been life on Earth, it was just microbes.
So all of us and everything else that you
see around here that's living, came out of
that soup of single cell organisms that was,
what was life here for most of the time that
there has been life. So microbes are a big
deal. And this gets into the world of extremophiles
which are microbes that live in places where
they should not be living. The research on
this started a number of decades ago but really
has picked up in the last 10 and then 5 years.
It began with the black smokers. These are
hydrothermal vents at the bottom of oceans,
basically something akin to a volcano erupting
there. The temperatures get up to 750 degrees.
There is nothing living right there at the
750 degrees but if you go out to 250, 200
which everyone assumed was well too high for
anything to survive, they're finding thriving
microbial communities. And if you go a little
bit further, you're going to find these long
tubeworms which is extremely bizarre.
In ice, this is a relatively new set of understandings.
This was being done at the Taylor Glacier
near, outside McMurdo in Antarctica. Researchers
go there. They dig into glaciers and they
find, they take out cubes, bring them home,
melt them and they find microbial life. It
turns out that, that when the ice crystallizes,
the H-2-O really stays in the center. Everything
else, salts, everything that isn't H-2-O is
kind of kicked out to a little tiny river
or whatever outside and that is the environment
in which the microbes survive. They get the
nutrients because it's been kicked out and
they are able and they have some kind of fluid
that they can, that they can work in. Until
1995, there was no knowledge really that,
that underneath the ice of Antarctica, there
is a huge set of lakes including Lake Vostok
which is roughly the size of Lake Ontario.
It's two miles down and the Russians are right
at the very edge of breaking through and into
Lake Vostok. They've been finding microbial
life along with other researchers all the
way down and the expectation is that down
in this lake, two miles down, they're gonna
find all kinds of living things.
Mono Lake in your neighborhood and its arsenic
bugs. You perhaps have read about this in
recent months and actually just today, there's
been additional information about it. This
was, there are two things going on here. Mono
Lake is a terminal lake. It doesn't go anywhere
so elements get very highly concentrated.
Arsenic runs off the Sierra Nevadas and into
here and so there's more arsenic here than
I think anywhere else. So it was interesting
when they found microbial life living in the
arsenic. But then some researchers took it
a step further and basically just doing benchwork
to begin with, worked on these microbes to
the point where they were, they were, essentially
the arsenic had replaced phosphorus which
everyone believes, and had believed until
that point, was essential for all DNA, for
all cell membranes, for a lot of other things
in the cell. And she had a paper, Felisa Wolfe-Simon
had a paper published last fall in which she
said,' We believe that, that these are creatures
that are entirely differ, potentially entirely
different than anything else that has originated
on Earth because it in fact does not have
the phosphorus but rather has the arsenic.'
It's a, it's a, the whole world is called
the 'Shadow Biosphere' and it raises the question
of, 'Well, if there was a genesis of life
here on Earth once, why not twice? Why not
three times? And what might be out there that
we're just not looking for and is there but
is, is in different forms that we, we would
not be identifying.' Very controversial. She
got clobbered for some of her research. And
the Blogosphere just went wild on this for
some time. Just yesterday, her rebuttal was
published in the Journal of Science and basically
she said, 'We think that we're on to something
here.' And while she's gotten a lot of enemies,
she got a lot of collaborators as well.
The Atacama Desert in Northern Chile, the
driest place on Earth. NASA goes down there
a lot for, for Mars Missions to see what conditions
would be like. It rains in some of the places
once every 10 years. You know a little bit
of rain and yet underneath the rocks, you
go down a little bit, you're gonna find again
microbial life; something that wasn't known
until 5, 10 years ago. I thought you folks
in particular would enjoy this. This is a,
an autonomous submersible that has been tested
down in Antarctica under the glacial ice in
one of these lakes and it can go on its own
up to a mile and a half, two miles and, and
collects data and it can make some kinds of
autonomous decisions about what might be interesting
and what might not be and then can come back
to this hole and come back up. This is not
so much an issue of being able to find things
we didn't know was there but it's, the technology
is gradually being put together for future
missions, and this is all about Europa. The
moon of Jupiter which is, has a huge crust
of ice and a vast ocean underneath the ice
and the expectation now is that it's, it's
one of the best possible locations for finding
[inaudible]. And of course, it's not going
to be easy getting through 14 miles of ice
to get through it. You might have to bring
in a nuclear weapon or something. But we'll
see how that works out. In any case, Tullis
Onstott, he's now at Princeton and a well-known
professor but he started off in the world
of extremophiles as an unknown guy. He had
no funding from NSF, no funding from anyone,
from NASA, anyone. He had done some original
work on, on looking for microbial life deep
underground, not in water but under the soil.
And was not really getting too far so he said,
'Okay. Where can I go really deeply down?'
And did research and found the deepest mines
on earth are in South Africa, the gold mines,
diamond mines. He took $6000 of his own money
and went to South Africa and made connections
with some scientists there and over a period
of a couple of years was able to go into some
of the mines and to go, you can't really see
it too well here but this is a bore hole where
a little bit of water is coming out. They
would collect the water and then take it into
their labs and see what they found. And after
some period of time, this is what they found,
this arrow like thing. It's called 'Desulfidorous
Audaxiator' which is the weirdest microbe
ever found. It is approximately 2.5 miles
down underground. It has been utterly cut
off from the surface of the Earth for they
think 10 to 40 million years, meaning that
it has gotten no organic material, nothing
that had to do with photosynthesis. It lives,
its energy source is the radioactive decay
of rocks and it, it uses that to break hydrogen
sulfide into elements that it can use to metabolize
and survive. It reproduces very slowly but
it reproduces. And as far as we can tell at
this point, it is, it is prevalent through
this, this area of, of South Africa. And the
implication of it is it's probably prevalent
or something like it is right below us too.
This is a whole new world that no one really
imagined more than 10 years ago that, that
the, that the microbial life deep down below
us actually there's probably a greater mass
of that than there is of life above the surface
of Earth.
This is just to show you that I indeed went
down there. It was very, very hot. It was,
the ambient temperature was about 140 degrees.
A hundred and sixty degrees inside the walls
and the, something that I had not fully understood
was that there's a lot, there's a lot of water
that comes through these through the little
fissures in rocks. And that sometimes there
are lakes and ponds within the rock and that's
where these microbes can live. And a lot of
it is just within the fissures of rocks. And,
and again, they, but they, they get the water
they need to get to do the tests from the
bore holes that are put in there. They get
it and they bring it back up. The, the aspect
of, of being down there that I found most
remarkable, it is very stark, very hot, very,
it feels like that if there is any place on
Earth where you're not going to find something
living, it's here. But as because of what
I knew, you walk through these miles of caves
or of tunnels and you realize there's life
everywhere. It's just like this little microscopic
stuff and it's in the rocks. And remember
my, to get to us, you need microbes so that's
where it all starts. Okay.
NASA is, the consensus view now and this is
again a, a, quite a new thing within the last
five or 10 years. The consensus view is that
Mars had a period four billion years or so
ago where it was quite wet and it was warm.
It had a mag -- some kind of magnetic field
which helped keep it, keep an atmosphere in
place which allowed for all of this to happen.
This is obviously a rendering rather than
a reality but we, we know that there are all
these gullies and deltas and whatever else.
And so there is now this view that Mars was
a potentially habitable place during that
period. This however was Earth at roughly
that period. We were getting clobbered by
a large, by a small planet that knocked into
us, became the moon. It was an extremely uninhabitable
place for probably half a billion years or
more. Through, through some of this geomicrobiology,
there has been the dates of the early, of
the detection of the earliest microbial life
goes back to about 3.8 billion years meaning
that life as far as we can tell began very
quickly. Either that it began very quickly
between roughly 4 billion and 3.8 billion
years and we have no idea how this happened.
But either it began very quickly or microbes
can live in very complicated, harsh environments.
An asteroid hits Mars, kicks up some, some
rocks that have microbes in them. They troll
around for a million years, two million years.
They land on Earth. We're all Martians. [laughter]
[pause]
This is Mars now. It does not look like a
very hospitable place. It looks like a beach
but without the hot dogs or anything. This
is, this is the Phoenix Mission which went
up two years ago or so. And it went to the
North Polar area and this is what it found.
It doesn't look like a big deal but that is
water ice and its right below the surface.
And this kind of confirms in a way what that
description earlier that Mars once had a lot
of water and was, and was no doubt warm. And
there is now an understanding that, that the
water, that this kind of ice is prevalent
throughout Mars under the surface. Here's
some more of those gullies. Now here is one
of the things to me that's very interesting.
Mike Mumma is one of the premier scientists
slash astrobiologists. Just to backtrack for
a second, he grew up in Lancaster County,
Pennsylvania which is a very conservative,
Amish area. He himself is not from an Amish
family but was very close to it. But he was
kind of an independent soul and had his own
sources of income when he was young. He had
a paper route and so on. So he was a free
thinker in that context and he would go to
church and in church he would be told that
life began 4000 years ago and there was no
such thing as evolution and blah, blah. And
then at age 11, he had his first science class
and he learned about evolution and that maybe
it was four billion instead of six thousand
years and whatever. So he went to his minister
and said, 'I don't understand. I am being
told such entirely different things.' And
as he described it, the minister told him
'The teacher was wrong and if you are going
to be in our church, this is what you have
to understand that.' So being the kind of
person that he was, he left the church and
became a - the kind of person who is kind
of the ultimate astrobiologist, who is, who
is taking nothing for granted, is challenging
everything, is, is eager to kind of take on
conventional wisdom, if, especially if, the
science or the knowledge is leading him in
that direction.
Well it took him 18 years but he came through
a year and a half ago with one of the major
discoveries of astrobiology. We know that
there is, there's trace amounts of methane
in the atmosphere of Mars and no one thought
it was a big deal since it was so little.
But what he did was, was to refine it and
say, 'Well, wait a second. There are trace
amounts but if you look at specific places,
at specific times,' and he did this with high-tech,
with extremely sophisticated telescopes and
spectrometers, 'If you look at specific places,
specific times, you're gonna find large outpourings
of methane' and this is something that's kind
of revolutionized again the understanding
of Mars because it means that either there's
life down there. 90% of methane on Earth comes
from biological sources. Doesn't mean that
this is necessarily biological but it would,
if it's not biological, then that means Mars
still is geologically alive which everyone
also assumed was not possible, that it had
died long ago. So methane on Mars is, is one
of the major breakthroughs and it, going back
to what I was saying earlier about the extremophiles,
it is a really interesting, potential insight
because there's this whole class of, of bacteria
called methanogens and they produce methane.
And they could be perhaps living way deep
underground in Mars. Maybe they were earlier
on the surface but then as Mars became far
more inhospitable, they went down. And so
now, they are sending out this. The, both
NASA and European Space Administrations were
sufficiently impressed by all of this that
they changed their whole plans for a, for
a mission in 2016, 2018. And it's gonna be
going to Mars to basically, to search for
methane. Just a little view here of what it's
like in -- this is a place called Paranal
in northern Chile. This is the place where
it never rains and so obviously there are
no clouds. And this is where all the big mirrors
are now being built, utterly spectacular,
utterly dry. They have an eight meter telescope
but, which is the largest that there is now.
No, I think the largest is 10 meters. But
the Europeans are now building a 42 meter
telescope so in, in the, the years ahead,
the ability to see things that additional
technology that will lead to additional knowledge
is already in motion. As I, I went down with
Mumma to Paranal and this is what it looks
like and, and I remember driving on that road
after going through the desert for two and
a half hours or so and arriving to that white
building and there wasn't a soul around. It
was like a neutron bomb had gone off. There
was just nobody and I had no idea where, where
the telescopes were, where anything was. But
I was ushered out of the car and brought to
this dome here, this, I'm not sure you folks
have it so much on the West Coast. But on
the East Coast, that's the kind of dome where
you put salt in for alongside the road when,
when the snow's gonna to be coming. So I'm
walking down here saying, 'Why am I going
to the salt dome?' But underneath the soil,
this is what they built. It is, this is the
residence for, for folks who work here. And
it is just extraordinarily beautiful and cool
and so bizarre in that kind of context. It
was, it was wonderful to be there and just
as an experience but it was also an insight
into what potentially sometime in the future
we can be doing, making on Mars or other places
that are equally un-, inhospitable. As it
turns out, the first astrobiology mission
to Mars since Viking which was 1976 is going
up this, this fall. It's called, this is called
'Curiosity'. It is orders of magnitude more
sophisticated than what happened when Viking
went up. Viking was a remarkable success.
Two landers survived. They made it down. They
did a bunch of tests, created a huge controversy
as to whether or not they found life. And
it's still being argued today. But, so they
had interesting technology but they didn't
have nearly sufficient technology and they
didn't have nearly sufficient knowledge. With
a lot more going on now, this thing's going
to be able to land and within a year or two
after the landing, we'll have some really
definitive answers about whether or not there
are organics there, whether or not there is
signs that there was life, that, that then
had impact on the rocks and other kinds of
things. So that is still going on despite
what everyone says that NASA is dead or whatever.
That's not true.
Okay. Step back for a second.
The universe is really, really big. This is
the number of stars in the universe today.
Every couple years they put another zero at
the end of it. It's, it's almost again to
me beyond comprehension. And the, well, in
the context of life, we'll see that this means
that the canvas that everything is being played
on is vast. This is the Hubble Ultra Deep
which again amazing pictures. All of these
dots are not stars but rather solar systems,
but rather galaxies, some of them a hundred
million light years across. And the faintest
things are, go back to 14 billion years. So
the magnitude of both the size of what we're
dealing with and the number of objects and
stars and whatever else we are dealing with
is huge and the amount of time is huge. So
when we think about life, it, it's, it plays
out in such a, in such large, in such a large
arena that when people say, 'Well, we haven't
been visited by anyone. How could it be that
there's intelligent life in the universe but
we haven't known about it?' Well, this is
just a small, teeny, tiny speck of the universe
that we know about and a very small, teeny,
tiny speck of time. There could have been
very sophisticated civilizations a billion
years ago and then they died out, as we will.
Okay. The, in terms of the logic of extraterrestrial
life, in recent years, they have also found
that everything needed for life is out there,
like way out there. This was a once exploded
star. The green are polyaromatic hydrocarbons
which are fairly complex rings of hydrocarbon
and so that's out there. Water's out there.
Oxygen's out there. Hydrogen's out there.
Nitrogen's out there. Everything that you
need for life is out there. And one of the
ways we know about this, I mean they have
been able to detect it through spectrometers
but they also know through meteorites that,
that land here. This is the best known meteor
or the most studied meteorite in history.
It fell in Australia in the late '60's, the
Murchison meteorite. And just very quickly
what they found in addition to a lot of interesting
stuff was virtually every -- there are 20
amino acids that make up the proteins that
make up us. These are amino acids are not
living things but they're essential building
blocks. All of the 20 amino acids that were
needed for life were found in the Murchison.
There were also, I don't know, upwards of
a hundred others that were non-terrestrial
so this clearly came from beyond but again,
so amino acids as well as water and hydrocarbons
are out there. As are nuclear bases also were
found in here. So again how things might be
coming our direction and into every other
planet. The world of exoplanets is, is really,
really hot right now. They are finding, they
have identified more than 500 exoplanets,
planets beyond our solar system. But, and
there are candidates of about 1500 more but
the expectation now is that they are, they're
out there in our own universe in the billions
in our own galaxy in the billions and in our
own universe in the many, many hundreds of
billions. So planets are extremely common.
This is the Kepler Mission which is going
out now to- it's looking at just one four
hundredth of the sky and it's trying to make
a census of, of the planets that are there.
It uses the, the transit, transit light system
where it identifies, it looks at the stars,
looks at all of the stars that are like a
hundred thousand, a hundred fifty thousand
stars at once and it looks for just slight
declines in the amount of light radiation
that's coming out. And if, if they could find
that a couple times, that means there's an
orbit and that means that there's a planet
going there. These are, this is actually the
grid that they look on. These are not the
actual planets but you can see that they're
finding not only super Jupiters which is what
they found early on, but getting down to Earth's
size and Neptune's size and so on. And now
this is very, very far away. I mean this is
hundreds of light years away. So they're doing
a census here. They're not trying to find
places where they might actually, where they
might actually go. However, this, this is
Paul Butler who is, I spent, I had the good
fortune of spending a lot of time with down
in Australia. He does a lot of different kind
of planet hunting. He uses radio velocity,
kind of the wobble of the sun, of the star
that would be created by the presence of an
exoplanet and so the gravitational pull is
-- very complex kind of stuff. But he, unlike
the folks who like to go to Atacama which
is so clear, he goes to this place in Australia
which, as you can see from the trees, is kind
of wet, which means that there's often a lot
of rain and not too many astronomers want
to go there anymore. But he loves going there
because to do his method, he has to be observing
a month, two months, three months at a time.
And so he goes there and does that. He just
sits there and every night and he is, he is
personally been responsible for, or personally
or as a team responsible for about half of
the 500 plus exoplanets that have been clearly
identified. And that's his Doppler shift method.
He somewhat controversially, he and a colleague
announced earlier this year that they had
found what, what was then considered to be
their first Goldilocks planet which means
it's in a habitable zone, close enough to
its star that, that there could be, that,
that water wouldn't boil away and also far
enough the other way around. Close enough
so there could be liquid water and far enough
so that there, everything wouldn't be frozen.
This is kind of the Holy Grail of, of the
Kepler Mission as well and of, of exoplanet
work generally is to find planets that are
in habitable zones. And most recently, a gentleman
named Geoff Marcy who is from your area. He's
at Berkley. He is another one of the great
planet hunters, put out a paper that based
on what they have found so far, this is like
extrapolation on extrapolation. But even so,
they said in our solar system -- I'm sorry.
In our galaxy, there is every reason to think
that there are billions of planets in habitable
zones. So final thing along these lines. They
are also able to find increasingly what kind
of chemicals are, what kind of elements are
in the atmospheres of stars far, far away.
Or planets, rather, far, far away. Mostly
they have found carbon dioxide and methane.
That's not biological kind of methane. But
what they're looking for is oxygen and ozone.
Oxygen binds very quickly with whatever's
around. And it, it will be found in large
amounts in an atmosphere only if there's something
biological there creating it. So if they find
oxygen or ozone in large amounts in, in an
atmosphere, in a very distant atmosphere,
then they're like 97% sure that they can then
say there's life there.
So, here's the logic of, of what I've been
putting together. And again, I'm a reporter
and brought this and an author now, hopefully
and brought this together from all these scientists.
But life, a lot more tenacious than previously
imagined; billions of exoplanets likely to
exist; habitable zones common; the molecules
and compounds needed for life as we know it
are out there. If life started once, why not
elsewhere? And, and here is kind of the clincher
in a way, and why finding microbial life on
Mars or Europa or wherever else might be so
important. If there's just one genesis in
our little solar system, then you say, 'Okay.
Maybe it's an anomaly. I don't know. Maybe
it's weird it would be an anomaly. But I guess
it's conceivable.' But if there were two,
if life started on two different planets and
it wasn't the same kind of life, then you
reach the point where probability says like
this, that life has to be a common place elsewhere
or across, throughout the universe. And it
would be impossible that just one chump change
kind of solar system would end up with two
varieties of, two origins of life.
So what are we looking for in terms of life?
Not this. It would be nice but not likely.
These are called 'snotties'. They're bacteria.
They grow in caves. They're very primitive.
You know it wouldn't be, it's not like it's
someone you could talk to but the whole logic
again is if you find it, then the logic of
evolution says that, 'Why wouldn't that turn
into a snow leopard someday?' Long day, long
in the distance. This is a nematode which
is going to be in the news next week. It,
there's going to be an article in the Journal
of Nature which says that in those same South
African mines that not only did they find
single cell microbes but they also found this
thing which is a roundworm which is complex
as these things go. That it has a nervous
system, it has a respiratory system, it has
a system to take in food and to get rid of
it. And they found it in the same, in the
same area not, they couldn't identify it as
being as old as the bacteria but it's kind
of as a proof of principle that you can have
complex life way, way down. It harkens back
to Mars and methane that might be coming out
of there and our understanding of where you
look for life and what life might be. Well,
he found it two miles down and was complex
life. This is just a fun thing. This was put
together by NASA. The logic of our understanding
of, of the world of the universe is, is like
so totally off reality. You could, if you
were in a, on a planet where there were binary
stars, photosynthesis could very easily not
only turn trees strange colors like this but
you could actually there was a paper that
was put out recently.
You can have leaves that are photosynthesized,
that are photosynthetic and are totally black
which I thought was a lot of fun. One last
step back. Alpha Centauri, this is the nearest
star system that has planets. It's 4.2 light
years away which by the comparison of a lot
of the other stuff seems like it's not much.
But since the whole idea of wormholes and
warp speed is fiction as opposed to fact,
our ability to get to places like this is,
is going to be, unless you guys come up with
it, it's not going to happen for a long time.
So what we're left with is SETI for better
or worse. When I started this, I didn't know
a whole lot about SETI and what I did I was
kind of skeptical, truth be told. But the
more I learned, I realized that one, it's
essential to this whole understanding, this
whole picture of, of extraterrestrial life
because if we do find microbial life on Mars,
how are we going to know what might else be
out there? It's too far away. So they're listening
and they also have gotten a lot of their science
is much more rigorous. They have this array
at Hat Creek. Forty two dishes now. They hoped
to go up to 500. Alas, they just ran out of
money to operate [laughs] so they're not operating
there anymore. But it was all money that was
donated, a lot of it was donated by Paul Allen
or other fairly wealthy and savvy people in
Silicon Valley. So it's not like they're saying,
it's not like this is craziness. Their partners
are the University of California Berkley Radio
Astronomy Lab. So its sophisticated stuff
and they will again get the money and they
will start once more. In my travels, I was
in, I went to Japan where their first ever
major SETI observation -- this guy is named
Shin-ya Narusawa. He wants to be the Carl
Sagan of Japan. And as you can see, he's got
already people, a lot of media there. There
were 23 observatories. Over two days, they
were all looking at one star system that had
been recommended by Carl Sagan and Paul Horowitz,
two of the icons of, of this whole world.
They looked. They didn't find anything but
the whole idea was to figure out a way to
do everything together. I will end with this
note. When I, after this was over and after
the stories began coming out about what they
had been doing, I was with Shin-ya and he
started to get calls, a lot of calls and he
was rolling his eyes and talking at length
and you could tell he was trying to calm people
down. And he's speaking Japanese; I didn't
know what he was saying. But I later asked
what was happening and he said, 'Well you
know whenever we do something like this and
whenever we, there's, there's press about
it, we get all these calls from people saying,
"Don't let them know we're here". [laughs]
"That this is dangerous". Now of course, we're
not letting them know we're here. They're
just listening. But there is this whole discussion
going on now about whether or not we should
also do METI which is 'messaging of extraterrestrial
intelligence' which for the most part is not
being done because of calls like this. And
Stephen Hawking very famously said the same
recently, that sending out messages would
be too dangerous. That when superior technologies,
or societies with superior technology interact
with those with inferior technology, meaning
us, that it always turns out poorly for the
latter. And so, but that's a discussion that
really, that's going on now and it'll be exciting
to, to follow. And a final thought, I kind
of bring this back to the world of belief.
I mean there is this incredible body of science
now that's been put together. And yet we're
now still left with this question of 'Well,
you know, extraterrestrial life. Is it bad?
Is it good? Are they going to hurt us? Are
they going to not hurt us?' And, and in a
way, it's sobering that that is still there
but it's the same process hopefully will occur
where belief is gradually kind of chopped
down and knocked in, and put aside as science
moves forward and finds realities which has
happened and hopefully will happen a lot more.
Thank you.
[applause]